certifications have served as a stepping
stone for anybody seeking to advance in
their careers whether they are beginners
or seasoned professionals
according to robert haff's 2021 it
salary report i.t professionals with
certifications earn 5 percent to 10 more
than their peers
so in this video we'll go over the
finest certifications that can help you
attain a good compensation
package at number 10 we have web
development
web development has been around for a
long time since every company needs a
website to advertise or sell their
products
this domain typically comprises three
categories front-end development
back-end development and full stack
development a certification in any
programming language such as python
nodejs html css javascript or angular
might improve your chances of snagging a
lucrative job offer
however if you are more inclined towards
full stack development than simply
learn's postgraduate program in full
stack web development in collaboration
with caltech might prove to be an
amazing option for you
this extensive course covers 13
different web development tools enabling
you to master front-end and back-end
development along with devops life cycle
the average salary for this domain
ranges from 62 000 to 158 000 in the us
and 13.7 lakh to 30 lakh rupees in india
next up we have number nine
cyber security
working remotely has become the new norm
since the covid epidemic but this has
brought a lot of cyber threats with it
due to remote access to it
infrastructure and the use of
collaboration tools on endpoint devices
to prevent cyber attacks companies need
certified cyber security and networking
professionals some of the popular
networking certifications you can pick
up are comp tia network plus
certification will provide you with
fundamental knowledge of networking
concepts network security network
operations and troubleshooting you can
also take up the cissp
cisco ccna and ccnp certifications
these certifications are considered
professional level certifications they
can show off your ability to work with
cisco networking solutions
a network engineer or cyber security
expert earns approximately eighty four
thousand to a hundred and sixty four
thousand per annum in the united states
and five lakh to 40 lakh rupees in india
at number eight we have agile scrum
scrum is a common framework for
collaborating with teams scrum
procedures enable businesses to
efficiently adjust with rapidly changing
requirements in order to create products
that align with constantly evolving
business objectives the scrum alliance
offers a certified scrum master
certification if you want to get started
with scrum
the certification will assist you in
comprehending the scrum framework as
well as team roles events and other
assets
it will also allow you to teach scrum
ideas concepts and practices to your
organization
a certified scrum master can earn up to
a hundred thousand to a hundred and
seventy thousand per annum in the united
states and up to 13 to 22 lakh rupees in
india
now for number seven we have robotic
process automation
rpa is a technique in which businesses
utilize ai and bots to run their
operations for instance if you launch a
web application to connect with the
support staff the first thing you'll
look into is the chat bot
the chat bot will present you with a
variety of questions and after you
select one it will offer you an
immediate response to your query
this is achieved using rpa to get into
this domain you will have to learn tools
such as blue prism
uipath and automation anywhere the
uipath academy provides you with free
training depending on the examination
you opt for
also you can opt for automation testing
masters program by simply learn
this course covers more than 15
automation testing tools and
technologies to make your profile stand
out as an automation test engineer
a certified rpa engineer can earn up to
88 000 to 140 000 per annum in the
united states and 7 lakh to 20 lakh
rupees in india
now for number six pmp certification
project management entails managing a
team to achieve its objectives and be
successful within a given time frame
some of the best certifications you can
obtain for this domain are
first there is the project management
professional certification provided by
the project management professional
the certification addresses domain
concepts such as initiating planning
executing coordinating managing and
closing
you can also pick up simply learn's pmp
plus certification which covers the
concepts of project management scrum
master lean six sigma and much more
with the proper certification a project
manager can make seventy five thousand
to a hundred and forty four thousand per
year in the united states and up to
twelve lakh to seventeen lakh rupees per
year in india
next up we have number five big data
big data is a discipline that permits
the analysis extraction and management
of massive and complex data collections
the following are some common
certifications that you can pursue
the associate certified analytics
professional credential allows you to
begin the analytics process it focuses
on many analytics areas such as business
issue framing analytics problem framing
and many more
you could also pick up the ccp data
engineer certification
this certificate allows you to
demonstrate your knowledge of ingesting
transforming storing and analyzing data
in cloudera's cdh environment a big data
engineer can earn 121 thousand to
251 thousand dollars per annum in the
united states
in india he or she can earn close to
12.3 lakh to 33 lakh rupees per annum
with the right certification
at number four we have digital marketing
businesses can only succeed if their
targeted customers are aware of their
product or services
thus digital marketing is an essential
component of every company's operations
as the area of marketing has evolved in
the digital era the demand for experts
who have been trained in new abilities
has increased substantially a digital
marketing certification can help you
hone the skills such as seo ppc web
analytics content marketing and social
media let's now have a look at some of
the best certifications you can pick up
first off you can take up simply learns
digital marketing specialist masters
certification or you can take up
certifications such as google ads
certification google analytics
certification and hubspot content
marketing certification
all of these certifications touch upon
concepts of digital marketing such as
seo content marketing ppc digital
analytics social media and so much more
a digital marketing manager could earn
sixty thousand to a hundred and sixty
thousand in the united states and up to
seven lakh to 16 lakh rupees per annum
in india
next we have number three data science
it is a branch of computer science that
integrates scientific techniques
algorithms and systems to extract
information and insights from organized
and unstructured data let's look at a
few top certifications that you can pick
up for this domain
first and foremost there is ibm's data
science professional certification this
ibm backed certification may help you
get started with data science python sql
data analysis and visualization building
machine learning tools and much more
harvardx's data science professional
certificate is another option for
accreditation it will cover our
programming data visualization essential
data science tools machine learning
methods probability inference and much
more by choosing the right certification
a data scientist can earn up to 115 000
to 246 000 in the united states and 8.2
lakh to 20 lakh in india
now for number two let's have a look at
cloud computing
no other area of it has produced as much
hype excitement and investment as cloud
computing during the last decade
according to idc by next year cloud will
attain a growth rate of 22
and a value of
277 billion dollars
and because of this there will
undoubtedly be a high demand for cloud
experts some of the popular cloud
computing certifications you can pick up
are
the aws certified solutions architect
associate certification
this certification will enhance your
ability to architect deploy and secure
applications on aws
to use the appropriate architecture
designs and much more you can also look
into the microsoft certified azure
administration certification which is
ideal for people who want to manage
cloud services that cover storage
security networking and cloud
capabilities
a cloud computing engineer can earn up
to 145 000 to
227 000 in the united states and earn
close to 16 lakh to 24 lakh rupees in
india with the right certification
and finally we're at number one ai and
machine learning
what if machines can provide you with
optimal data-driven decisions by
perceiving patterns in previous data
sets
how amazing will this be right
this astounding fact about ai and ml
domain has made it one of the most
popular career choices
in the previous year's trends ai has
shown a staggering 344 percent growth
and the right certification can help you
do wonders in this amazing domain a few
of them are simply learns postgraduate
program in ai and machine learning
created in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
covers a number of concepts like
statistics python machine learning deep
learning networks nlp
reinforcement learning and more
machine learning ai certification by
stanford available on coursera is also a
good resource this course includes an
introduction to machine learning data
mining statistical pattern recognition
the best practices in machine learning
and ai etc
an ai engineer can earn 140 000 to
386 thousand dollars in the united
states and six to 20 lakh rupees in
india
and there you go that's our top 10
certifications to take up in 2021
with that we've reached the end of this
video do you agree with our list think
we missed anything important let us know
in the comment section below
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here